[Music]
darkness is the cannabis and the light
is my brush with light painting you can
create new worlds into darkness my name
is Hana Ultimo and I paint would like I
[Music]
live in Finland we have amazing nature
here we have a long summer nights that
are warm and full of light but on the
opposite there is also this dark part
it's called polar night it starts in
December and it lasts for about fifty
days the Sun doesn't rise above the
horizon at all and for a light painter
that is quite good I do long exposure
photography which is a photographic
technique that allows me to draw with
light the exposure times can vary from a
seconds to hours and the idea is to use
the light sources as approaches or
pencils and the dark surroundings are
the cannabis when I start I might do
some sketches on paper after that I go
to the location I search for details
that I want to emphasize with some light
treatment it will start to look like a
completely a new place going to dark
woods or to abandoned house you first
think that oh I don't want to go there
because there's just so nasty looking
dark places but too light painting I
have examined these places and they look
beautiful you see the place differently
[Music]
[Music]
you got offices you just got posted
offices which is kinda personal kisi
tokino in Satya famous it is 10 years on
Amazon a very Heaney acuity and ok NIOSH
so graffitis you got the offices yet to
give moto graph what he knows sibel
octopus a statistic me mana scimitar a
personal feel important job
specificities meeting protea pizza dough
Mad Max who can I get this - Sally I can
approach Pataki Mauricio pieces para
poor limited on hands
Tina's espalda to mama Alma catastrophic
me so Paula Mia's Agra Festina Gaddafi's
delicate amasau retrieves metaseries
Maris if the host party Tomasso to
project at OPM massive colony tools
after pooh Menem meperidine e chemically
para police nafisa immaterial to many
authorities to Nassau graph is what is
needed offices here you see a note in my
physician Mia
we have Akashi up wellif Roseboro 1403
Camaros in a tie game in the premiere at
lava cave o+ karate master Kelly vu Jana
gimme anoxia Nagini Premera
tisket a tasket mo mada in a Kathy Topp
you can Akito keaton 13 proceed is
Lucifer etiquette ahora de mato Bravo
final vignette in Nia button Bernama
pecks with available methods over half
years
unhappy - pure entrepreneur Hedorah
pure eto curico
I started painting music just because I
would try to explain synesthesia so many
times it never quite made as much sense
to describe it verbally so I thought it
would be best just to put it on canvas
just because I've always been an artist
and it made it much easier for people to
be able to understand it my name is
Melissa McCracken and I am a synesthetic
artist synesthesia is a neurological
condition where your brain is basically
cross-wired
so certain stimuli will come in and
it'll create the wrong response in my
brain so from me that's listening to
music and it's translated into color in
my head I'm going to paint superstition
by Stevie Wonder I love the song
superstition just because it's dynamic
and funky and just fun and expressive
whenever I start a piece I just listen
to the song first to even know what kind
of colors I'd like to use there are some
songs that I hate that I'd like the way
that they look a little bit like a lot
of pop music and can be pink and purple
and you know just all these fun bright
colors but songs not that good so one of
the other I appreciate it somehow you
know you kind of really have to be in
the right vibe to be able to paint if
you're not in the right vibe you're not
gonna make anything good
I think the prettiest onra of music is
jazz music I love blues and golds and
whites and it just seems very pearly and
iridescent a little bit when I listen to
Etta James at last the thing that stuck
out most to me was just her voice but
very beginning when she goes into the
last
then it's just a very bright and but
also warm sort of feeling and very kind
of classic jazzy which jazz music
generally has a very gold and blue sort
of look to it
music has always been a very big part of
my life and my older brother is very
musical
and when I think back of him playing the
guitar for me I think of the colors of
what those memories are I was always a
little disappointed because I was never
very musically inclined it was really
cool to have a way to bring music and to
you know my life in a different sort of
way what I do is more than a manicure
it's micro activism you can be cute and
multifaceted and vocal about your
message my name is Aimee Vega and I'm a
nail artist out of New York City I
became a nail artist by chance it was
always something I did for myself since
I was maybe 13 years old and I thought
about it and I wanted to pursue it more
seriously so I went to nail school and
got my license so I work on fashion
shoes but neora is mostly what I do
I think socially conscious nail art is
important now more than ever because of
the things going on not just in our
country but all around the world
everything under blacklivesmatter
women's rights LGBT rights women's
health domestic violence against women
is also another one
no matter what you have on your nails
they bring attention it brings your eyes
to their nails it kind of brings the
conversation into real life nowadays we
depend so much on social media and it
kind of just brings that interaction of
person to person somebody will see your
nail art and want to inquire and then
you have a moment an opportunity to talk
about that topic it's more than just
being cute and having cute nails it's
having a message and feeling strong
about it and be vocal about it as a
woman sometimes we were made to be a bit
more submissive and this is a way of
kind of getting strength in our own
messages and saying hey I am gonna be
cute but I also have a message to say
and I'm gonna wear it on my fingers you
know
so being activists means to feel
strongly about something whatever it may
be more than anything staying true to
yourself and your message
[Music]
you
[Music]
the main difficulties of working with
any vulnerable or fragile work of
cultural heritage is the respect you
have to have for that object technology
is at a point right now where we can
record the surface of an object down to
fractions of a millimeter and it's
through this kind of understanding that
allows you to communicate across time
and across cultures and the task of
heritage protection and preservation is
a real challenge
the mission of factum foundation is to
record cultural heritage so in the event
that there's a disaster or an accident
we have the data to know what was there
exactly as it is we're pioneering a
number of methods to return that
information into the physical world
we're doing CNC milling we're doing 3d
printing but we're trying to go beyond
that a facsimile of the Borg are in each
Apple the facsimile of the tomb of
Tutankhamen in the Valley of the Kings
an exact facsimile of Vera nasals
wedding at Cana
[Music]
[Applause]
the biggest project that's going on at
the moment is an exact facsimile of the
tomb of Seti the first which will be
given to the people of Egypt as soon as
it's finished two hundred years ago the
concern was not one of preservation the
concern was one of Indiana Jones and
discovery and excitement and cultural
acquisitions the tombs in the Valley of
the Kings lasted successfully for three
thousand three and a half thousand years
but since they've been visited they
start to decline and decay rapidly
I think the facsimile is opening up a
whole new level of possibility for
display preservation conservation
restoration communication dissemination
of what's important about these objects
if only we can preserve it like it is
and document it and hand it on to future
generations then there's hope
[Music]
you